Es muy difícil hablar,
al final de una conferencia como esta.
Todo el mundo ha hablado. Todo está dicho.
He pensado que lo más útil será recordar
alguna de las cosas que se han dicho aquí.
Así podemos extraer ideas
en las que trabajar y sacar adelante.
Eso es lo que quiero intentar hacer.
Vinimos para hablar de "África: el siguiente capítulo"
Pero al hablar de "África: el siguiente capítulo":
miramos al pasado y al presente. Lo vemos y
decimos que no fue muy bueno.
Estas fotos que muestran sequías, muertes y enfermedades
es lo que solemos ver.
Pero queremos ver "África: el siguiente capítulo".
que tiene la cara de un africano sano, sonriente y guapo.
Creo que es importante recordar lo que hemos oído
en la conferencia desde el primer día,
donde se dieron las estadísticas
del momento actual
y de lo mucho que ha mejorado el continente.
Lo importante es que tenemos una plataforma sobre la que construir.
Así que no perderé mucho tiempo
en haceros recordar que
estamos aquí por el siguiente capítulo, ya que es la primera vez
que tenemos una plataforma sobre la que construir.
Realmente tenemos una posibilidad,
el continente está creciendo a un ritmo inimaginable.
Décadas después, hemos pasado del 2 al 5 por ciento
y se estima que pasaremos al 6 o incluso al 7 por ciento.
La inflación ha disminuido.
La deuda externa, de la que tengo mucho que contar
pues trabajé en una de las deudas más grandes del continente,
ha descendido drásticamente.
Como pueden ver aquí ha descendido
de 50 billones a 12 o 13 billones.
Esto es un gran logro.
Hemos acumulado reservas. ¿Y por qué es importante?
Porque respalda a nuestras economías y monedas
y nos da la plataforma para construir y crear empresas.
También vemos indicios de que todo esto está marcando la diferencia,
pues la inversión privada ha aumentado.
Quisiera volver a recordarles...
Sé que ya han visto estas estadísticas.
Hemos pasado de 6 a 18 billones.
En 2005, sólo en Nigeria, las transferencias
como ven la subida es espectacular
y continúa aumentando drásticamente.
Esto también ocurre en muchos otros países.
¿Por qué es importante? Demuestra confianza.
Ahora la geste confía y trae...
Si su gente en la diáspora trae el dinero,
demuestra a otros que, miren,
hay una confianza emergente en tu país.
y así, el dinero en lugar de salir comienza a entrar.
¿Por qué es importante hacerlo tan rápido?
Construir la plataforma es importante,
y escuchar al presidente Kikwete y otros líderes que dicen:
"Tenemos que hacer algo diferente"
porque nos enfrentamos a un reto.
El 62 por ciento de la población tiene menos de 24 años.
¿Qué significa esto?
Que tenemos que centrarnos en cómo la juventud
se involucrará de forma productiva en la vida.
Centrémonos en cómo crear empleo,
en que no enfermen y en su educación.
Y sobre todo, en que hagan algo provechoso en la vida
y en que crean un ambiente productivo
en nuestros países, que hará que las cosas cambien.
Para apoyar esta causa, una de las cosas
que he hecho tras dejar el gobierno
es fundar una organización de estudios de opinión pública en Nigeria.
La mayoría de los países no tiene estudios de opinión.
La gente no tiene voz.
No hay forma de saber lo que quieren.
Les preguntamos qué era lo que más les preocupaba.
Y al igual que en el resto de países,
el trabajo es la primera preocupación.
Me detendré aquí para luego retomarlo.
Antes de ver esta diapo quiero contarles algo.
Para mí, el siguiente paso tras construir la plataforma,
que hoy nos permite avanzar
y a la que no hay que restarle importancia.
Hace apenas 5, 6, o 7 años,
ni podíamos hablar del siguiente capítulo pues estábamos en el anterior.
Íbamos hacia ninguna parte.
Nuestras economías no crecían.
El crecimiento per capita era negativo
El marco microeconómico y los cimientos para salir adelante
no existían.
No olvidemos que ha costado mucho construir esto,
incluidas las cosas que intentamos hacer en Nigeria.
Implantamos un programa para solucionar problemas como la corrupción,
creamos instituciones y estabilizamos la microeconomía.
Por eso tenemos esta plataforma para construir.
Esto nos lleva al debate que se ha mantenido aquí:
ayuda frente al sector privado, frente al comercio, etc.
Alguien alzó la voz y dijo que era frustrante
la simplicidad del debate.
Y que el debate no debería ser así.
Sería participar en el debate equivocado.
El tema aquí es cómo crear una sociedad entre donantes gubernamentales
el sector privado y ciudadanos africanos,
que tomen las riendas de su vida.
¿Cómo se combina todo esto?
para salir adelante y hacer las cosas necesarias
de las que os hablé antes. Los jóvenes tienen que trabajar.
Tiene que fluir la salvia creativa del continente
y hemos podido ver mucha de ella aquí.
Así que creo que nos hemos equivocado de debate.
Es necesario que se vuelvan a preguntar
¿qué combinación de factores
nos permitirá conseguir lo que queremos? (Aplausos)
Les voy a contar una cosa.
Para mí las ayudas...
No creo que los africanos tengan que irse al otro extremo
y sentirse mal por las ayudas.
África ha estado dando ayudas a otros países.
Mo Ibrahim dijo en un debate que
el sueña con el día que África ofrezca ayudas.
Y yo le dije, "Mo, tienes razón... pero ya lo hemos estado haciendo!
El Reino Unido y EEUU no podrían haberse construido sin la ayuda de África."
(Aplausos)
Gracias a todos los recursos extraídos de África,
también humanos, se han construido estos países.
Por lo que si quieren devolver algo, no deberíamos ofendernos.
No deberíamos discutir eso.
La discusión es cómo utilizar aquello que nos devuelven.
¿Cómo lo estamos utilizando?
¿Se está utilizando con eficacia?
Os quiero contar una historia.
El porqué acepto la ayuda si la usamos bien.
Entre 1967 y 1970 Nigeria vivió la guerra de Biáfara.
A mediados de la guerra tenía 14 años.
Pasábamos casi todo el tiempo cocinando junto a mi madre.
Para el ejército, mi padre era un brigadier del ejército de Biáfra.
Estábamos del lado de Biáfra.
Sólo comíamos una vez al día, íbamos de un sitio a otro,
y ayudábamos en lo que podíamos.
En un momento dado, en 1969, las cosas iban muy mal.
Casi no nos quedaba nada, en relación a la comida.
Los niños morían de Kwashiorkor.
Estoy segura de que los menos jóvenes
recordaréis aquellas fotografías.
Pues bien, yo estaba en medio de todo eso.
Entre tanto mi madre enfermó del estómago dos o tres días.
Pensamos que se iba a morir.
Mi padre no estaba allí.
Estaba en el ejército.
Yo era la más mayor de la casa.
Mi hermana enfermó gravemente de malaria.
Ella tenía 3 años y yo 15.
Tenía tanta fiebre, lo intentamos todo.
Parecía que nada le ayudaría.
Hasta que supimos que a 10 kilómetros había un médico que podía...
que ayudaba a gente y daba medicamentos.
Me puse a mi hermana en la espalda. Estaba ardiendo.
Caminé 10 kilómetros con ella a mi espalda.
Hacía muchísimo calor. Tenía mucha hambre.
Tenía miedo. Sabía que su vida dependía de que llegara hasta aquella mujer.
Oímos que había una médico que trataba a la gente.
Andé como pude los 10 kilómetros.
Llegué y vi multitud de gente.
Había más de mil personas intentando tirar la puerta abajo.
Trataba a la gente en una iglesia. ¿Cómo iba a entrar?
Gateé entre las piernas de la gente
con mi hermana atada a la espalda.
Encontré una ventana.
Mientras la gente intentaba tirar la puerta abajo,
trepé por la ventana y salté dentro.
La mujer me dijo que había llegado justo a tiempo.
Cuando saltamos dentro, ella ya casi no se movía.
Le inyectó cloroquina (entonces supe lo que era la cloroquina),
le dio un poco para rehidratarle,
y otras medicinas y nos puso en una esquina.
El cabo de dos o tres horas empezó a moverse.
La envolvieron en una toalla, pues empezó a sudar,
lo que era una buena señal.
Y por fin mi hermana se despertó.
5 o 6 horas más tarde nos dijo que podíamos volver a casa.
Me la até a la espalda.
Caminé los 10 kilómetros de vuelta y fue el paseo más corto de mi vida.
¡Estaba tan feliz (Aplausos) por ver a mi hermana con vida!
Hoy tiene 41 años y es madre de tres niños,
y es un médico que salva vidas.
¿Por qué os cuento esto? Os lo cuento porque
si eres tú, o alguien cercano a ti,
te da igual de dónde venga la ayuda.
¡No te importa lo que sea! (Aplausos)
¡Tan sólo... tan sólo quieres que esa persona viva!
Dejadme que os diga de forma menos sentimental que el salvar vidas,
que es lo que hace parte de la ayuda en este continente,
la vida de cualquiera: un granjero, un profesor, una madre...
contribuye de forma productiva en la economía.
Como economista, también miro esa parte de la historia.
Estas personas son agentes productivos en la economía.
Por lo que si salvamos a la gente con VIH/SIDA o con malaria,
pueden formar parte de la base productiva de nuestra economía.
Y de la misma manera,
como dijo alguien ayer, si los dejamos y mueren,
sus hijos serán una carga para nuestra economía.
Así que incluso desde un punto de vista económico
apartando lo social y humanitario,
debemos salvar vidas ahora.
Esta es una de las razones, desde mi experiencia, por la que digo:
canalicemos los recursos que recibimos hacia algo productivo.
Sin embargo, también os diré que soy
de las que no cree en una solución única.
Por eso he dicho que el debate ha de ser más sofisticado.
Tenemos que aprovecharlo bien.
¿Qué ha pasado en Europa?
¿Sabíais que España, miembro de la UE,
recibió 10 mil millones de dólares en ayudas de la UE?
Recursos que les fueron transferidos,
¿se avergonzaron los españoles? ¡No!
¿En qué emplearon los 10 millones?
¿Habéis ido hace poco al sur de España? Hay carreteras por todas partes.
Infraestructura en todos lados.
Gracias a esto, todo el sur de España
se ha convertido en una economía de servicios.
¿Sabíais que Irlanda recibió 3 mil millones de dolares en ayudas?
Hoy Irlanda es una de las economías de crecimiento más rápido de la UE.
Por lo que muchas personas de todo el mundo,
van allí en busca de trabajo.
¿Qué hicieron con los 3 mil millones en ayudas?
Construyeron una súper autopista de la información,
aumentaron infraestructura que les permitió...
les permitió participar en la
revolución de la tecnología de la información.
Y por eso, crearon trabajo en su economía.
No dijeron que no querían la ayuda.
Hoy, la UE no para de transferir ayudas.
Mi frustración es que si pueden construir infraestructuras en España,
tales como carreteras, autopistas y otras cosas,
¿por qué no quieren utilizar la misma ayuda
para construir la misma infraestructura en nuestros países?
Si es eso lo que les decimos que necesitamos.
Una de mis preocupaciones es que tenemos muchas fundaciones.
Hablamos del Banco Mundial, del FMI, de la responsabilidad...
y de la UE.
También tenemos ciudadanos con mucho dinero.
Algunos están en este auditorio, y tienen fundaciones privadas.
Y un día, esas fundaciones con tanto dinero,
superarán la ayuda oficial que se está dando.
Pero tengo miedo, y les estoy muy agradecida
por lo que intentan hacer en el continente,
pero me preocupa. Me despierto con un mal presentimiento.
Veo emprendedores con ayudas en el continente.
Y van de un país a otro,
muchas veces buscando qué hacer.
Pero no estoy segura de que su asistencia
esté siendo canalizada adecuadamente.
Muchos de ellos no están familiarizados con el continente.
Lo están descubriendo.
Y muchas veces no veo africanos trabajando con ellos.
¡Van por su cuenta! (Aplausos)
Muchas veces tengo la impresión de que ni les interesa
escuchar a los africanos que pueden saber.
Quieren venir de visita,
ver lo que pasa en el terreno y tomar una decisión.
Puede que esté siendo dura.
Pero estoy preocupada pues ese dinero es muy importante.
¿Ante quién son responsables?
¿Estamos en las directivas cuando toman decisiones
sobre dónde canalizar el dinero? ¿Estamos ahí?
¿Cometeremos otra vez el mismo error?
Alguna vez nuestros presidentes, de los que todo el mundo habla,
han reunido a toda esta gente y le han dicho,
"Miren, su fundación y la suya,
traen mucho dinero. Estamos muy agradecidos.
Sentémonos y les diremos adónde debería ir el dinero,
adónde debería llegar esta ayuda."
¿Lo hemos hecho? La respuesta es no.
Cada cual hace su esfuerzo de forma individual.
En 10 años habrán entrado miles de millones en África,
pero seguiremos con los mismos problemas.
Esto es lo que nos deja sin esperanzas.
Nuestra falta de capacidad de sentar a la gente que trae dinero y decirles:
"Siéntense."
Y no lo hacemos porque somos muchos. No nos coordinamos.
No hemos llamado a Bill Gates ni a Soros,
ni al resto de los que están ayudando y no hemos dicho:
"Vamos a mantener una reunión con vosotros.
Como continente tenemos estas prioridades.
Esto es para lo que queremos utilizar el dinero."
No todos deberían ser emprendedores
que van en busca de lo que es mejor.
No queremos detenerles. Para nada. Queremos ayudarles a que nos ayuden.
Y lo que me decepciona es que no estamos haciendo nada de esto.
Dentro de 10 años estaremos hablando de lo mismo,
repetiremos las mismas cosas que hoy.
Así que el problema es cómo podemos aprovechar
todas estas buenas acciones que nos están llegando.
Cómo conseguir que el se gobierno combine adecuadamente
con las fundaciones privadas, las organizaciones internacionales
y con nuestro sector privado.
Creo firmemente en el sector privado.
Pero no lo pueden hacer solos.
Podemos pensar en algunas ideas que hagan que esto funcione.
Estos encuentros son para compartir y difundir ideas.
¿Por qué no pensamos en aprovechar parte de la ayuda?
Mejor aún, por que no les decimos a los que nos ayudan:
¡No temáis a la infraestructura!
La sanidad no se mantendrá si no tenemos infraestructuras.
La educación será mejor
si tenemos electricidad y carreteras, y otras cosas.
La agricultura mejorará con carreteras por las que llevar los productos al mercado.
¡No la despreciéis!
Invertid parte de vuestros recursos en ella.
Veremos como esto es una combinación
del dinero privado, internacional, multilateral,
del sector privado y de los africanos y podemos asociarnos
para que la ayuda sea ayuda.
Eso es la ayuda.
La ayuda no resolverá nuestros problemas. Estoy totalmente convencida.
Pero puede ser catalítica, y si la usamos de otra manera
habremos fracasado.
Una razón por la que China goza de simpatía en África
una de las razones, no es por aquello de: esa gente es tonta
y China viene a llevarse recursos.
Es porque podemos aprovechar mejor la ayuda de los chinos.
Si les dices: "Aquí necesitamos una carretera"
ellos te ayudan a construirla.
No les asustan las infraestructuras.
De hecho, el ministro de Finanzas chino me dijo,
cuando le pregunté qué hacíamos mal en Nigeria.
Tan sólo se necesitan dos cosas:
Infraestructura, infraestructura, infraestructura... y disciplina.
Sois indisciplinados. (Aplausos)
Y se lo repito al continente.
Es lo mismo, necesitamos infraestructura y disciplina.
Podemos hacer un catalizador que nos ayude a conseguir algo de eso.
Pero, no me refiero a que la salud y la educación
se dejen de lado, hay que procurarlas también.
No digo que sea una cosa u otra.
Asociémonos para las ayudas.
Esto es una idea.
Otra idea, para el sector privado.
La gente tiene miedo de arriesgarse en el continente.
Porqué no utilizar ayudas para generar un mecanismo de garantía,
que permita a la gente asumir riesgos.
(Aplausos)
Por último, porque ambos están... He agotado el tiempo.
¿Se me ha acabado el tiempo?
Vale, no quiero olvidarme de lo más importante.
Una de las cosas en las que quiero que todos colaboren es
en apoyar a la mujer, en crear empleos. (Aplausos)
Se han dicho muchas cosas sobre la mujer, no es necesario repetirlo.
Pero hay personas, mujeres, que están creando empleos.
Y sabemos, por lo que los estudios muestran
que cuando pones recursos en las manos de una mujer,
sobre esto hay un estudio econométrico,
un informe del Banco Mundial del año 2000, que muestra
que las transferencias a mujeres daban como resultado
niños más sanos, mejoras para la casa y para la economía.
Lo que digo es que una de las lecturas que tenemos que sacar de aquí,
no digo que los hombres no sean importantes,
obviamente, si quitas a los maridos, ¿qué harían?
Al volver a casa se disgustarían,
y generaría dificultades que no queremos.
No queremos que los hombres peguen a sus mujeres
por no tener trabajo y esas cosas.
Pero al margen, queremos, yo quiero resaltarlo
pues la razón es, los hombres automáticamente
reciben casi siempre más apoyo.
Quiero que se den cuenta que los recursos
en manos de la mujer africana es una herramienta potente.
Hay gente creando empleo,
Beatrice Gakuba ha creado 200 puestos en su negocio de flores en Ruanda.
Tenemos a Ibukun Awosika en Nigeria, con los muebles, la empresa de sillas.
Quiere expandirse.
Necesita 20 millones más.
Creará 100 o 200 puestos de trabajo más.
A partir de ahora pensad cómo unificar
los recursos en manos de mujeres que están a mitad camino,
que están preparadas:
son empresarios que quieren expandirse y crear más trabajo.
Y por último, ¿qué vais a hacer
para formar parte de esta asociación de ayudas, gobierno, sector privado
y los africanos como individuos?
Gracias. (Aplausos)